人真的是没有对和错的，
我就像没有钱的时候，
没有200万的时候，
可能我们想谁要是能给我百万的话，
我能给他伺候小月子，
等到你真的有了200万的时候，
你又要谈感情了，
就像我图的是你的钱吗？
我图的是你的感情，
我图的是你的在乎，
我图的是你的尊重。
人就是这样的，
我很贪心的，
我是97年，
我老公比我大五岁，
相处了八年，
结婚五年，
有一个两岁的宝宝，
我老公家她是有一个小目标，
我们家就是普通家，
娘家没什么背景，
也就100多个资产，
现在我结婚的时候，
娘家也没有给我任何东西，
我们认识了之后在一起三年，
感情也挺好的，
但是我当时是在外地上班，
我普通本科，
但是找得还行，
找了一份国企的工作，
一年有十七八个，
但是当时他跟我结婚的要求就是我要辞掉这份工作回他家上班，
他妈会给我入社保，
每个月给我5000多块钱，
因为我们是小地方，
他觉得这钱够我生活，
其他的开销他也会给我。
当时我也同意了，
因为毕竟有感情基础，
我们就回来结婚了。
结婚的时候他妈妈是给了我30个彩礼加乱七八糟的，
结婚一个月我就发现他在我他那边说的礼金，
他微信上的都输光了，
当时他是给我。
说他再也不走了，
还欠三四个，
我手里有点钱，
我就帮他还了，
过了半年她又走了，
我就告诉他妈妈了，
因为他们家是他妈妈在管理，
他妈妈是那种女强人类型，
我就觉得这个事情我已经做不了主了，
因为他又就告诉他妈妈了，
当时是他妈妈管他很严格，
我结婚前不知道呀，
后续结了婚他才告诉我他有抑郁症，
而且是很多年，
这些是我不知道的，
他的抑郁症是他家里造成的，
他结婚前是对我隐瞒的，
包括他们家里人都是对我隐瞒的，
但我就觉得结了婚了，
你对我还行，
咱们俩也能过下去，
有感情了，
他我，
我也原谅他了，
我知道这块是那种底线，
但我原谅他了，
他又我他妈就送他去医院治疗，
他妈也是一个挺开明的人，
他妈就了解我，
他属于心理层面，
他妈妈去送他医院花了20多个，
当时疫情就是得关在里面，
我是有陪着他，
我觉得我做的可以了，
我觉得可能熬过去，
我们以后日子也会很好过，
但是回来了之后这几年他陆陆续续一直在进行这个事，
那种小刀腊肉每次有啊，
他妈妈也没有第一次那么激动了，
给他还了，
可能过一年半年又一个几万，
他妈妈又觉得他心理问题，
我不能逼他，
如果我失去我儿子怎么办？
这这个也一直在治疗，
这些年也花了不少钱，
我也一直在陪着。
她我们生了孩子之后，
经济上都是她父母在负担，
她妈妈经济方面对我还不错，
但为什么我现在想离婚了？
还有一个事情就是我们没有夫妻生活，
生了孩子之后，
她就一直在吃那种心理的药，
吃了很多就没有夫妻生活，
现在已经两年了，
这些我也都忍了，
我就把他妈妈当一个老板，
我就说嫁给别人可能还不如他，
还有生活矛盾，
男人都一个样，
那只要他妈妈给我钱，
我孩子好好生活，
我就在这家里好好生活，
在我说实话对他的不满一直在领居嘛，
这么多事情就是扶不起来的，
阿斗在家里他也没有任何话语权，
但是生在他妈妈还比较大方，
今年他妈妈是给了我200个，
他还爱玩，
他白天睡觉晚上出去玩，
回来就打架了，
我知道我不该动手，
我知道这个我错了，
我打了他，
他也打了我，
但是对于我爸妈的说，
他要真想打你，
你不会这样，
我身上没有名声，
他没有给我下重手吧，
可以说是，
但是他反击了，
我也找了帽子叔叔，
他妈妈当天就想让他去加号那里验一下，
我觉得他妈妈是有留一手的，
但是他能去，
我现在想真的跟他分开，
我问题一就是他这200个，
他如果找我要还能拿回去，
这个事情得看双方有什么聊天作为证据，
如果说有聊天作为证据是能定义为赠与的性质，
那就是送给你的，
送给你的也。
不等于你一个人的，
等于是夫妻两口子的，
他这些年陆陆续续都有给我转钱，
就是不交200多，
对这个东西得看上下文，
得看聊天记录，
得看这个钱他转的时候有没有什么备注啊，
有没有什么特别的事情啊，
你要问我说能不能被他拿回去，
我只能告诉你确实存在着这种可能性。
举个例子吧，
假设他和他妈妈之间有一个借款的合同，
有一个借款的条子，
你不知道也存在这种可能性，
假设你们之间有曾经聊过，
说啊，
等我们日子好了，
妈妈这钱我再还给你怎么样？
有这样的聊天，
也有可能被认定是一种借款的行为，
借款的关系，
那不还就是老赖，
这个事情还未必，
这200万以及以前婆婆给你的这些钱，
他有以下几种可能性，
一种可能性，
认定为是赠与的法律关系，
如果是赠与的法律关系的话，
不太可能被认定为是赠予给你个人单独的，
大概率下会被认定为是赠予给你们夫妻两口子的，
如果你们两口子要分的话，
那还是要分这个钱的，
这对你来说已经算是比较好的结局了，
认定为赠与的关系了。
第二种可能性呢，
比如说他妈妈和他的儿子私底下有借款合同，
或者从你们的聊天记录里面可以推测出来，
这个钱将来你们两口子是要还给奶奶的，
还给婆婆的，
好，
这有可能被推定为一种借款的关。
那么是借款的关系的话，
它也是你们夫妻两口子共同的债务，
为什么呢？
因为这个钱实际上是花到了两口子家庭的开销了，
养孩子了，
就会认定为是你们两口子共同的债务，
如果你们要分开的话，
要共同来承担这笔债务，
这个对于你来说是更不好的一种结局，
就好的结局，
这个你钱现在去买一个房子嘛，
说是婆婆给我们让我们买房子的，
其实你拿这笔钱去做什么，
这件事情已经不会去反向的推导这笔钱的法律性质了，
这笔钱的法律性质可能在现在此时此刻他已经形成了，
但他是给我的大额存单存到我卡里，
他没有聊天记录什么的，
但平常他微信上也会一直给我转，
那你说之前的钱怎么解释都是赠与，
他不会有借什么的，
但现在这笔钱又怎么定义，
因为这笔钱是刚给钱，
还没有花，
这笔钱怎么定义的话，
我说了不算，
姑娘可能还要看当时转账记录里面有没有什么备注啊，
转账的那个时间节点，
你们之间有没有发生什么事情啊，
有没有什么聊天的记录，
包括他的儿子跟他之间有没有什么聊天的记录啊，
这些都要看，
甚至如果我是以后当婆婆的话，
我可能让我儿子在微信里面管我借200万，
把这200万打给你，
我能知到这么机会知道没有，
所以我说我现在是没有办法帮你来判断这个。
200万到底是借款关系还是赠与关系的，
最终是要上了官司，
上了法庭，
法官通过你们之间的这些聊天记录啊，
这些事情来判断的，
除了这200万，
还有个40的存款，
这个是他们都不知道，
我自己存下的，
我们夫妻共同财产我觉得应该都没有，
我的都是全款，
婚后他有给我买四个车位，
但是这个车位算财产嘛，
花了40个当然算他产了，
我能要求分割吗？
在你名下当然是可以啊，
在你名下如果是婚前给你买的，
严格意义上来说算是你的婚前个人财产，
不是是婚后婚后买的，
不是在我老公名下婚前全款买的，
这个车位是婚后买的，
婚后买的那是你们夫妻共同的呀。
其实我有一个比较折中的方案后，
尽量财产放在你的孩子名下，
其实我觉得如果这个婆婆一年能够给200万的话，
这婆婆真是相当不错，
就当给婆婆打工了。
对于婆婆来说，
我们有一个统一的利益，
有200不让我花的，
她就是说要给我女儿存下的，
对呀，
那多好啊，
我给我女儿买门面，
给我女儿买房子，
我可以跟着我女儿住，
我不也间接提高了我的生活条件吗？
我之前也忍了她，
我没有生活，
但是她这次动手了，
我就怕这次是你先动手的，
不是人家先动手的，
是你。
打的他。
但然这个事情最终是要尊重你的意愿，
我只是说你和你婆婆之间有一个共同的利益，
这个共同的利益点就是你的孩子，
如果说一个婆婆能给你200万的存款的话，
那100个婆婆里面你找不出一个。
这么说我没毛病，
给200万的婆婆是找不出来的，
我老公就是没本事，
我要跟她混下去，
就得什么都听我婆婆的。
我婆婆是一个特别强势的人，
姐妹们，
你要是有一个亿，
你也强势，
回过头来说，
如果你老公什么条件都那么好，
没有任何缺点的话，
轮得到咱们吗？
你要是有一个亿，
你也强势，
如非我要是有一个亿，
我都不知道我强势成什么样，
我都不知道我能狂成什么样，
我绝对强势啊，
我他妈妈把他手机拿了，
我么打了架，
他妈妈就觉得他委屈，
他妈妈又把手机给他了，
他一次次赌博，
其实是他妈妈一直在放纵，
他又有心理疾病，
跟抑郁症的人生活在一起是件特别累的事情，
我也理解你啊，
那刚才你的问题我给你讲明白了，
是不是关于法律上的，
关于钱财上的，
关于财产怎么分的，
我给你讲明白了，
那你还有什么问题要问我呢？
还有我女儿，
我孩子我是一定要要的，
你你再嫁人，
你还要给人家生孩子，
我也不想嫁人，
如果这个钱我能拿到手的话，
当成可以给我的吧，
她有精神方面的疾病，
请问你儿，
我问你下你女儿现在是多大了2岁，
如果你现在就去申请离的话，
就女儿。
分给你的概率比较大，
因为是个小姑娘，
又才刚刚满2岁，
所以分给妈妈的概率比较大一点，
但前提条件我觉得你还是得出去，
不依赖婆婆的情况下，
你还得找个谋生的本事。
我也看弹幕说了，
劝我不跟他分开，
但我现在生活挺痛苦的，
我也理解你啊，
我只图他钱，
我可能无所谓，
我是有感情基础的，
在一起8年我做不到，
他做任何事情我都无视他。
我本来是想忍忍的，
孩子上幼儿园了，
自己干点事情能独立了，
但是你对他是有感情的，
你对这个人是有期待的，
你理对，
而且他家一定会强这个孩子的，
他现在也生不了别的孩子，
他是因子质量不行吗？
不是她吃药吃的特别多了，
那她停药了不就可以生了吗？
我觉得他家一定不会放弃这个孩子，
我妈也未必，
因为如果说有钱到他那种程度的话，
他有很多方法要生孩子的，
只要停药，
她只要有个小蝌蚪，
她就能变出孩子。
我当时晚上带着我孩子回娘家，
我婆婆是我给我抢孩子的，
抢肯定是强，
但是你说他们以后就不容易生孩子了，
这个想法是你太天真了，
她抢肯定会抢这个孩子，
但如果抢不到的话，
人家可能再生个3个5个的都很正常，
如果这种情况你建议我跟他反看你这种情况，
坦率的说啊，
你自己多去找情感主播呀，
心理咨询师啊，
多去找这些人多聊一聊。
再看看你身边周围和你家庭背景差不多的那些人，
现在过的是什么生活，
因为人真的是没有对和错的，
就像没有钱的时候，
没有200万的时候，
可能我们想谁要是能给我200万的话，
我能给他伺候，
小心月子，
等到你真的有了200万的时候，
你又要谈感情了，
就想我图的是你的钱吗？
我图的是你的感情，
我图的是你的在乎，
我图的是你的尊重。
人就是这样的，
简安乐泰的那个李娟说的，
人很贪心的，
总是被困在一个欲望里面，
你200万你真的能做到，
你老公你别说他，
他在外面，
他跟生孩子你都不管有没有，
我帮你看看现实啊，
但是我依然没有办法穿着你的鞋过你的日子，
帮你做这个决定。
是的，
我自己之前其实是一直想忍的，
把感情放下，
包括夫妻生活这个事儿啊，
千人千面，
什么叫千人千面呢？
有的姐妹她生完孩子了之后，
她巴不得老公不找她，
我们直播间一定有这样的姐妹，
她生完孩子了之后，
她甚至巴不得老公在外面找一个别来烦我，
其实也没有这方面特别多的需求，
我会不自信，
自信这个事儿不是在男人身上去找的姐妹，
自信这个事儿是如果我能作为一个情绪稳定的妈妈，
我的孩子跟我在一起的时候，
她非常的愿意跟我在一起，
也愿意成为我的样子，
她也是我自信的来源，
如果我自己在工作上能够让我的上下游工作伙伴都觉得跟我工作。
很愉快，
如沐春风，
跟我工作有前途，
跟我工作能赚到更多的钱，
她也是我自信的来源。
如果我能跟婆婆关系处理挺好，
我甚至能学到婆婆的本事，
我能赚到跟婆婆一样的钱，
那也是我的自信来源。
自信的来源绝不能从一个男人身上去找，
就儿风险太大，
你主动他拒绝，
你就会怀疑自己。
嗯，
千万别那么想问题，
我跟你说，
哪怕你长得像奥黛丽赫本，
哪怕你长得像丹米奇，
哪怕你长得像那个谁，
婚姻这个事儿啊，
不像那个小欣姐说的那话似的，
他说你喜欢吃西瓜，
你特别喜欢吃西瓜，
一直吃，
你不可以碰别的水果，
不可以吃别的水果，
你到最后的话，
你不可能再喜欢吃西瓜。
所以千万不要觉得哪个男的拒绝我了，
就打击我的自信啊，
啊，
男道多的是啊，
千万不要这样想问题啊，
都是我一直过得挺好的，
他一直在折腾，
不断的剩现问题，
嗯，
过了一段好日子，
他就会蹦出来，
行吧，
今天咱俩就聊到这儿，
你回头可以在评论区找答案，
你看评论区的其他女的怎么看待这个问题，
跟咱差不多的年纪，
差不多也生了孩子的娘家也没有什么太大帮衬的，
他们怎么看待这个问题，
或许对你也有帮助，
行，
那我也考虑考虑大家的意见，
因为他家现在就每年还有200多个的收入，
着急做决定主要是自己的心理健康，
自己要关注，
多跟人聊天，
什么情感主播呀，
心理咨询师啊，
花钱聊好，
就这样啊，
谢见。
嗯，
还有一个事要跟大家聊。
啊，
这个社会总是把男人批不批，
男人搞不搞外，
男人在外面怎么怎么样，
跟这个女人去挂钩，
好像这个男人批了，
这个男人在外面找别的人了，
就好像说是这个女人的失败，
什么时候我们才能把这个逻辑练给他理顺，
男的也好，
男的在外面找外也好，
这个是男人他自己的事儿，
是他自己堕落，
是她自己嫁三滥，
跟女人有什么关系？
我绝不会因为说谁的男人啊，
谁的男人在外面找人了，
我就觉得这个女的不优秀，
就觉得这个女的再没有魅力吧，
绝不这么想问题，
我希望我所有的姐妹也能明白这个逻辑，
并且运用这个逻辑，
这样的话，
我们女人在这个社会上的生存空间和生存环境就会越来越好。
记得点赞关注哦。